نحن الآن داخل أسوار
مدينة الرقة القديمة ، عاصمة داعش هي
الخلافة المعلنة من تلقاء نفسها
والأراضي التي سيصنعون فيها موقفهم النهائي
في سوريا وفي
الواقع في الشرق الأوسط هذا الجدار
علامة بارزة لقوات التحالف
والأكراد السوريين و  العرب الذين يسيطرون الآن
بشكل كامل على حوالي مائتين أو ثلاثمائة متر
داخل المدينة القديمة هنا على هذا
النحو على
مسافة 200 متر هي مواقع داعش ، والقوات
هنا
لا تتحرك كثيرًا في وضح النهار
بسبب خطر وجود قناصة داعش بشكل أقل
في هذه الشوارع ولكن  إنها ليلة
جعلت غالبية الحركة إلى الأمام في الواقع
قد رأينا قواتنا هنا ليست بعيدة
عن هذه المواقع قلقة من عدم
تصويرها أو حتى ملاحظتها بصراحة ، لكننا
نفهم أنها تستدعي
الضربات الجوية وغالبًا ما
تسمح المدفعية  هذه القوات للمضي
قدمًا بصراحة وبسرعة كبيرة ،
لقد فوجئت بمدى ضآلة وجود تنظيم الدولة في
المدينة على ما يبدو في الوقت الحالي في
منطقة من
المحتمل أن تكون على بعد ميل ونصف إلى ثلاثة أميال
من حيث
الحجم الصغير جدًا في
التضاريس التي يسيطرون عليها ، لكن
كما رأينا في الموصل بالعراق ،
يبدو أن المدنيين محتجزين في وسطهم غير قادرين على
الفرار بسبب قناصة تنظيم الدولة ،
وهو ما يمثل عائقاً حقيقياً أمام هؤلاء
المقاتلين الأكراد والعرب السوريين ، ولكن لا يزال
التقدم هنا يشير إلى
احتمال وجود  آخر مرة
يقول فيها تنظيم الدولة أنهم يسيطرون على مدينة
أه في سوريا ، نيك
بيتون والش CNN داخل مدينة الرقة القديمة ، سوريا.